and we are all ready to say goodbye
aren't we to 2020 and welcome 2021 right
here on channel 8.
for 30 years now we have been counting
down the new year and this year we will
once again take you through every time
zone starting with the ball drop over in
times square in new york city
and ending right here in las vegas so
this year we're going to be live from
stadium swim
inside circa with performances from zoe
bowie
the eli young band and strip headliners
like tape face
we want everyone to have a safe new year
so we will be social distancing like all
of us are
and getting tested as well and during
what's been a trying year for so many
we will also be raising money for food
banks all across the country
with the super bowl of caring our goal
is to hit
1 million meals any money you donate
will stay
right here in las vegas we're excited to
do that and we hope you stay safe if
you're staying home
join us the show kicks off at 8 59 our
time
runs through 12 35 again